follow me
so
with faith in jesus christ we receive
the body
of our brother john william warner
for burial let us pray with confidence
to god
the giver of life that he will raise him
to perfection
in the company of the saints
deliver your servant john sovereign lord
christ
from all evil and set him free
from every bond that he may rest with
all your saints
in the eternal habitations wherewith the
father and the holy spirit you live and
reign one god forever and ever
amen let us also pray
for all who mourn that they may cast
their care
on god and know the consolation
of his love
almighty god look with pity upon the
sorrows of your servants
for whom we pray remember them lord in
mercy
nourish them in patience comfort them
with a sense of your goodness
lift up your countenance upon them and
give them peace
through jesus christ our lord amen
you
please stand as you are able
i am resurrection and i am life says the
lord
whoever has faith in me shall have life
even though he die and everyone who has
life and has committed himself to me in
faith
shall not die forever as for me
i know that my redeemer lives and that
at the last he will stand upon the earth
after my awakening he will raise me up
and in my body i shall see god
i myself shall see and my eyes behold
him
who is my friend and not a stranger
for none of us has life in himself
and none becomes his own master when he
dies
for if we have life we are alive in the
lord
and if we die we die in the lord
so then whether we live or die
we are the lord's possession happy from
now on
are those who die in the lord so it is
says the spirit for they rest from their
labors
good morning and welcome to washington
national cathedral
my name is randy hollereth and i am the
dean of the cathedral
and on behalf of marianne buddy the
bishop of the diocese of washington
and all of us who serve this cathedral
it is an
honor for us to be able to host this
service today this cathedral is a house
of prayer for all people
and we are indeed honored to be able to
welcome all of you
senator warner was a great friend of
this cathedral and we celebrate his life
and lift up his legacy today so let us
begin with singing oh god our help in
ages past
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
distinguished clergy members of the
congress
and our military and distinguished
guests
jeannie virginia john
mary and andrew the warner family
it's a great honor to be invited to
speak a few moments about john
a few days after john's passing i
visited arlington national cemetery
on memorial day a sacred place
on a solemn day when we undertake
the fundamental act of of remembrance
and amid the moments that i was there
and the monuments of stone
we remember each marker represented
a precious life remember the heroes
of the greatest generation the world has
ever known
and that bears a noble name
the united states of america
the only nation founded on an idea
they were all created equal endowed by
our creator
with certain inalienable rights
including life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness
and a democracy that is the very soul
of our nation and must be defended
at all cost a soul
embodied by all those patriots buried in
arlington
in the fields across the world and
by our dear friend john warner
like many here i had the privilege of
serving with john
for three decades in the united states
senate
while we represented different political
parties
i can say without hesitation
john was a man of conscience
character and honor
with a deep commitment to god and
country
enlisted in the navy in the united
states navy at age 17
to fight in world war ii
a few years later enlisted in the marine
corps
to fight in korea
eventually named secretary of the navy
by president nixon
then elected to the united states senate
where he became a
towering and respected voice on foreign
policy
national security and defense
the second longest serving senator from
virginia
the longest serving republican
a member of the greatest generation and
as that he understood
that democracy is more
than a form of government democracy is a
way of being
he understood it begins and grows in an
open heart
and with a willingness to work across
the aisle
and come together in common cause
and that empathy empathy
is the fuel democracy the willingness to
see each other
as opponents not as enemies
above all to see each other as fellow
americans
even when we disagree from john's
perspective especially
when we disagreed that's how
john forged consensus and made sure
our system worked and delivered
for the people i saw it time and again
on issues of war and peace
john opposing torture
and ending gun violence i'm protecting
the rule of law
and the independence of the judiciary
john's decisions were always guided by
his values
by his convictions and never
by personal political consequences
and was always guided by his obligation
to all those he represented even
those who did not vote for him
every senator wears the pride of his or
her state
on their sleeve but john's love for the
people of virginia was something special
and they loved him back and kept
reelecting him
because they knew john
understood the job of senator was bigger
than himself
it was about more than just john
and as we say in the senate excuse me a
point of personal privilege
when john endorsed me for president last
year
it carried an extra meaning for me
the senators and congresspersons here
will understand this
it wasn't merely that a prominent
republican endorsed me
when john endorsed me it gave me
confidence
not about winning about being able to do
the job
john gave me confidence
you know in the battle for the soul of
america today
john warner is a reminder
what we can do when we come together
as one nation
while we've never made real the full
promise of america to all americans
john's life is a reminder that
every generation every generation
has opened the door of opportunity a
little bit wider
everyone and the mission handed down
generation
to generation is to work
of perfecting the union a mission
he now leaves us with a way forward
that's the power of remembrance
it lies not just on our history
but in our hope for the future
not just in our solace but in our
strength
it lies in our hearts to continue the
work of democracy
the work of our time
of all time in the work of john's whole
life
to john senate staff
thank you for your service for all
you'll do to carry on john's legacy
and to his family jeannie virginia
john mary andrew jill
i know it hurts to remember
sometimes just hurts to remember
but it's also the way to heal
to remember the bible teaches
blessed are they that mourn for they
shall be comforted
while comfort can be a long time in
coming
i promise you it will come
it will give you purpose
in his memory and his love for you
and his love for this country
virginia i know you'll be reciting your
father's favorite poem
sort of an anthem
here's another one that describes him so
well in my view
it means a great deal to my family
and to me it's called american anthem
the work and prayers of century have
brought us to this day
what shall be our legacy what will our
children say
let me know in my heart
when my days are through america
america i gave my best to you
john warner gave his best to america and
the best of my knowledge to everybody he
had a relationship with
may god bless him he was a good man
a great american it was an honor
to have known him and work with him
mr president congressional leaders
distinguished guests and the warner
family
it is a great privilege to spend a few
minutes
recalling this great man
my first warner sighting was in 1971.
we all remember ours don't we
i was in the pack wardroom of the
aircraft carrier uss
america while deployed to the sixth
fleet
in the mediterranean then under
secretary of the navy john warner
addressed
hundreds of officers after a major nato
exercise
at the height of the cold war i was a
young lieutenant jg
sitting in the bleacher seats all the
way in the back
i don't remember everything that he said
but i sure
do remember the way he made us feel
he was a galvanizing riveting
some would say almost swashbuckling
presence
that electrified the audience especially
with his storytelling
which was legendary the navy at that
time was in heavy seas with a new and
revolutionary cno
even as our country was in great
internal turmoil
while fighting a very unpopular war in
vietnam
yet here was john warner leading from
the front
in very difficult times and reassuring
all of us in the strength of our nation
and in the brightness of our future as
he would today
i am sure he made us
he made me feel proud
proud to be in the navy proud to serve
my country
proud to be an american just like him
i will always be grateful as i'm sure
everyone here is
for my professional and personal
relationship
with secretary senator chairman
john warner deborah and i want to
express our deepest and heartfelt
condolences to the genie and the entire
warner family
he was truly a great man and an
extraordinary
patriot and he will be sorely missed
i am most grateful for his untiring and
relentless support
of our young women and men in uniform
he was always our champion
we knew that and we needed that
his life encapsulated much of our
nation's history in war and peace
starting with his own service in uniform
he and i often greeted each other
recalling the fondness
of our youth he would refer to himself
as petty officer third class warner
and i would always respond as lieutenant
mullen
we both knew who outranked whom
but no one was prouder of his own
service than john warner
his time as an enlisted sailor in world
war ii and as a young marine officer
in the korean war truly shaped the rest
of his life
many years later while in service to the
great commonwealth of virginia
and our nation our paths would cross
frequently
and sometimes intimately as we were yet
again
a nation at war this time in iraq
and afghanistan as chairman of the
senate armed services committee his
wisdom and
insight were powerful even critical
he chaired that committee in true
bipartisan fashion
always leading with integrity while
seeking to do what was best
based on his unwavering principles
he spoke out early and often on the need
for the united states to adhere to the
geneva convention
and he denounced torture he was a steady
even keeled voice in a growing cacophony
of partisanship
we could count on him to lead with his
values
now john warner loved all of the
branches of the armed services
but he really loved the navy
always dressed to the nines he very
frequently wore his blue and gold
striped tie and man did he
love navy ships he loved to
fund them he loved to build them
especially in virginia
hold on to ceo or a lack of funding for
building
he said i'm sure you know admiral that
the constitution gives congress the
responsibility to
raise an army but it also calls on us to
provide and maintain
a navy he said there was a big
difference between those two
sets of verbs it meant that there would
always be a navy
and that meant we'd always be building
ships
and that meant i'd better get after it
if i knew what was good for me
and now one of those ships is his
namesake
the uss john warner ssn 785
and the love of his life jeannie is her
sponsor
uss john warner is the first of the
virginia class submarines to be named
after an individual
how fitting is that i can still see john
and jeannie's beaming faces on the day
that ship was commissioned
and his broad grin he looked like a
possum eating a sweet potato
and we know how proud both genie and he
were of their ship's crew
if you want to know just how much think
of this
chairman warner wore his honorable
service pin from world war
ii on the lapel of his suit jacket for
30 years
as a senator that same pin now resides
in the ship
that bears his name yes he loves ships
but he really loves sailors in typical
warner fashion he would spontaneously
call up one of the enlisted sailors on
his submarine just to say hello and add
a thank you
for what they were doing for our country
he would sometimes regale them with sea
stories
and some of those stories were actually
true
he liked to recall his bus trip to nate
his bus trip to navy boot camp
it was 1944 the war was still raging
john was a skinny scrappy young lad of
17.
he had to get his parents permission to
sign up
anyway somewhere along the route he got
the idea to throw all the underwear his
mother had given him out the window
i'm sure there was a moral to that one
but i never quite figured it out
and he would only wear his submarine's
ball cap with the embroidered
silver dolphins of an enlisted
submariner
not the senior officer's ball cap with
the gold scrambled eggs
you always knew where his heart was
that crew will miss his visits and his
phone calls
no question and like him
and us they will never forget
in every way over the course of his life
john warner was the exemplar
even in the waning years of his life he
reached back to world war one
a war his father dr warner fought and
was gassed in
senator warner helped establish the
recently opened memorial near the mall
to recognize the more than 4.7 million
men and women who served in that war
including 116
000 who gave their lives for freedom
and democracy he often reminded me of
the need to be constantly ready as
as he was well aware we had let our
guard down
after world war one in fact
i was last with him here in this special
cathedral
as the nation commemorated the
anniversary of 11
11 11 the month the day
and the hour of the end of the great war
we walked arm and arm down this very
aisle together
the petty officer and the lieutenant
friends and shipmates
john warner is defined by his service to
the american people
but the most important part of his
legacy is his family
three children virginia john mary
and two beloved grandchildren his pride
in you was and
unbounded and our hearts ache for
and with you and no one has had more
impact on him than you genie
and we as a nation are so grateful for
you
john was indeed sent by god for you as
you once said
more importantly you were sent by god
to him he was a lucky guy
he knew it and so did we
so chairman senator colleague
sailor marine
friend and shipmate we bid you farewell
we will miss you greatly i will miss you
greatly thank you for always making me
feel proud
just like you did so long ago in that
hot stuffy wardrobe
aboard uss america i so much look
forward to the day we can again greet
each other
as we always did petty officer third
class warner
and lieutenant mullen fair winds and
following seas
petty officer warner may you rest in
peace
in the loving hands of our lord
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when troubles come
and my heart
then i am still
[Music]
waiting
[Music]
by me
you raise me up
so i can stand on mountains
[Music]
i am strong
when i am on your shoulders
that i can
[Music]
you raise me up
so i can stand on mountains
you raise me up
to walk on stormy seas
i am strong
when i am on your shoulders
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you rise me up
[Music]
i am strong
when i am on your shoulders
raise me up to more than i
can you raise me
[Music]
i am strong when i
am on your shoulders
[Music]
you're lazy
[Music]
two
ginny to the on our children
and grandchildren and family lisa and i
joined so many
here today offering our deepest sympathy
mr president fellow members of congress
and many distinguished virginians and
friends
we're gathered here today to pay our
respects
to a great american a great virginian
and so many of us here today a great
friend
john owner was a statesman he was a
public servant
most of all he was a patriot
as we've heard john had a career that
stretched from world war
ii and korea to 30 years in the united
states senate
so nobody needs to be told
that john warner loved his company
country
and believed in public service
but what some folks might find more
surprising
in this day and age is that despite
our political differences he was my good
friend
now i don't mean that in the way that
sometimes we
in the senate like to call somebody you
can't stand
my friend on the floor of the senate
i mean he was my actual
honest-to-god personal friend and we
cared
deeply about each other
and john warner's friendship isn't the
kind of thing
that you take for granted because
frankly giving the way that we first got
to know each other
he would have been well within his
rights
if he had not decided to give me the
time of day
it was back in 1996.
i had never run for public office but i
decided it would be a good idea
to challenge senator john warner who is
running for his fourth term
now for the virginians remember that
warner versus warner race confused the
heck out of everybody in virginia
just about the only interesting thing
that our campaign came up with
was this clever bumper strip that said
simply on it
mark not john
and honest to goodness i've told this
story many times
i was campaigning one day down in
danville i got out somebody looked at my
car saw the bumper strip and said
excuse me sir is that a biblical
reference
well there was no divine intervention
that year
and at the end of a spirited but
respectful campaign the right warner
won the race and i will be forever
grateful that afterwards rather than
holding
the campaign against me as many would
john who was already a towering
institution
in virginia politics while i was frankly
just a young upstart
we built a friendship
that's who john was a class act
he was also frankly a lot of fun to be
around
but more than that this has already been
mentioned
he was a leader of substance who
delivered for virginia
and for his country for 30 years in the
united states senate
admiral mullen has already indicated
there isn't a
sailor soldier airman
or marine anywhere in virginia for that
matter
anywhere in the country who doesn't owe
a debt of gratitude
to john warner he could always be
trusted to put
country and commonwealth ahead of
politics
john never shied away from taking a
tough position
even if sometimes it invited criticism
i remember when i was governor we were
dealing with a multi-billion dollar
deficit we didn't know what
we were going to do so i called our
senior senator
to see if he'd be willing to weigh in
come down to richmond
and help us close the gap with some of
the legislators i needed to convince
again i was a democratic governor
calling a senior
republican senator to get involved in a
state issue
and the truth be told even some of his
most loyal
senior staff who were here advised him
not to do it
you know what john did of course he said
mark if you want this for
virginia i will be there so we smuggled
him into the governor's office
trying to make sure the press wouldn't
see
i had a conversation he went up to the
third floor and did his own press
conference
and he said politics be damned and he
stomped the podium he said this is the
right thing to do for virginia
it was like zeus had come down from
olympus
and you know what we got it done
virginia kept a triple a bond rating we
made a record investment in education we
got named the best managed state
and i don't have a doubt in my mind
that that would not have happened if
john warner
hadn't been willing to put his own
personal capital
on the line for what he thought was
right for virginia
virtually everyone here who served with
him could stay here all day
and tell stories
about john warner like this because
unlike so many in elected office
john warner was never afraid
of putting his credibility his
reputation his good name
behind something when it mattered
i think about the 1994 senate race
think about his involvement
questions about the iraq war i think
about his again as admiral mullen and
president biden already said
his constant willingness to fight
for a strong defense sometimes that
earned john criticism
from folks on my side and folks on his
own side of the aisle
asked for his response to that criticism
john said simply
that's the price of leadership
until the day he died
john never hesitated to speak out when
he think
thought things had gone astray in recent
years
despite his ostensible
from public life he spoke often about
the concern for our country for our
leaders
for his beloved senate which he often
worried
had lost his way over the last few years
i had a great honor john and i
did a lot of joint appearances joint
speeches
last year at the age of 93
john was kind enough that
once again he'd endorse me in 2014 he
endorsed me again
so he said he'd come to a fundraiser for
me and it is genie as you know one of
the great honors of my life
that he was kind enough to support me
remember the event john got up
did the introduction i got up
gave my pitch was winding down thinking
gosh
we can go home now john stood back up at
this point he's
using a walking stick and just cracked
me in the shins
and said sit down mark i've got some
more to say
and for the next 30 minutes john told
stories
only in a way with all due respect to
all the senators here
only in a way that john warner could
boy oh boy everybody got their money's
worth that night
the truth is for all his disappointments
with the current state of our politics
and the institution he loved the u.s
senate
one thing i loved about john is he never
lost his burning sense of optimism
even the last time i saw him back in
march
i'd visited him on try to revisit him on
a regular basis
he reminded me that it didn't have to be
this way
that each day was a new opportunity
when you walked into the capitol to do
the right thing
for our country
whenever i'm wrestling with a tough
question i try to think myself
what would john warner do and i know if
i follow that mantra
chances are i've done the right thing
and that matters i see so many of my
fellow virginians here
because in virginia we tend to ask a lot
from our elected officials
we expect them to serve but to maintain
dignity
we expect them to lead but to stay
humble
we expect them to fight for what they
believe in but remain
respectful john warner
was the embodiment of all that
and so much more
i will miss his counsel his humor
but most of all his friendship
may this american hero rest in peace
to genie and the entire warner family
ann and i feel for you very deeply in
your loss
but we are so honored to be
here with you today together with the
president and first lady
and so many admirers of john warner's
long before i knew john warner the
patriotic
public servant i was honored to consider
john warner a friend
and it was only upon coming to the
senate four years after he retired
that i came to fully understand
the mark that he left on the senate and
on his beloved commonwealth
and on his nation john was a friend
through my wife's family
anne's father lynnwood came back to
washington and lee
after service in the pacific in world
war ii
and was joined in his fraternity by
another young man
also returning from navy service
lynn and john began a friendship there
in 1946
that lasted for 75 years
lynn and john worked with a small band
to build the virginia republican party
so that virginia would not be a
one-party state but instead
a true competitive two-party democracy
lynn lobbied president-elect nixon
in 1968 to appoint john as first under
secretary and later
secretary of the navy john then
supported lynn's campaign
when he was elected the first republican
governor of virginia in 1969
lynn campaigned with john to help him be
elected to the senate
in 1978 and then john helped lin
become a member of the board of amtrak
i often at family events heard their
stories
about the path of virginia politics and
their hopes for more progress
for our commonwealth and country
when anne broke the news about john's
death to her dad
now aged 97
he expressed profound sadness
at the loss of his friend of seven and a
half decades
then after a long pause lin said
wait a minute he's still a youngster
he's two years younger than me
that statement tells you something about
my father-in-law but it also conveys the
truth about john
he's still a youngster there was always
a youthful energy
curiosity twinkle in the eye
and slight sense of mischief about john
warner
as i entered public life what impressed
me most about john
was his obvious belief that
country and character count above all
else
as mayor of richmond and then as
governor of virginia i often ask for his
help
and if i could convince him it was right
he would deliver
he was a republican and i'm a democrat
but that never mattered
it never mattered it was always
inspirational to me
that he never hesitated to choose the
path of
country and character instead of simply
going along with the orthodoxy of the
day
that example should continue to
challenge
us all here's something else that should
challenge us john warner ran to the
fight
twice to defend his country
joining the navy as soon as he graduated
from high school
during world war ii and then
re-enlisting
in the marine corps during the korean
war
he did this at risk to his life
to his health to his career
but of course he prioritized defending
the nation above all else
john warner saw the capital of this
nation under attack
on january 6. he was deeply saddened
by the assault on our democracy
we all should be will we step up
to defend our nation as john did
finally john gave me a personal
challenge
when i asked his advice about running
for the senate
in 2012. he did not support me
in that race because i was running
against his close friend george allen
but in response to my question about
whether the job
was worth the pain of campaigning to get
it
john said this if you'd asked me that
question in 1978 when i got here
i would tell you to run for the senate
if you have a one percent chance of
winning
it's the best job you could ever imagine
i can't say that now because
partisanship
and fundraising and polarized media
have made it a tougher place to find a
path to do good things
but you know what old friend it's not in
the water supply
it's not sick building syndrome it's in
the character and the priorities
of the people who walk into the building
every day
so if you decide to run and are lucky
enough to have the chance to serve
you can make it better
when i arrived in the senate in 2013 and
joined
john's cherished armed services
committee
i finally began to understand john's
impact
from these stories that i heard
about his three decades of service
in the senate he loved his senate
colleagues and the senate colleagues
loved him
and just to be clear his senate
colleagues were not just senators
far from it his superb staff
still powerfully connected as warner
alums
committee staffs capitol police
food service employees senate gym
employees
they were all family to john for 30
years
a few months after i came to the body i
invited john to join me in the senate
dining room for lunch
he told me that he had not been in a
long time
i have never felt as popular
in the united states senate as the day i
walked into the dining room with john
warner
and i doubt i ever will feel as popular
everyone flocked to our table
his smile his laugh his relaxed banter
told me that surrounded by his friends
he felt completely at home
and so we gather here today for a man
who exemplified love of country and
character
and surrounded by his friends and family
i address john warner as he used to
address me
well old friend today
you're at home
please stand as you are able
the lord be with you
let us pray
o god whose mercies cannot be numbered
except our prayers
on behalf of your servant john and grant
him an
entrance into the land of light and joy
in the fellowship of your saints through
jesus christ our lord who lives and
reigns with you and the holy spirit
one god now and forever
amen most merciful god
whose wisdom is beyond our understanding
deal graciously with john's family and
friends
in their grief surround them with your
love
that they may not be overwhelmed by
their loss
but have confidence in your goodness and
strength to meet
strength to meet the days to come
through jesus christ
our lord please be seated
for everything there is a season
and a time for every matter under heaven
a time to be born and a time to die
a time to plant and a time to pluck up
what is planted a time to kill
and a time to heal
a time to break down and a time to build
up
a time to weep and a time to laugh
a time to mourn and a time to dance
a time to throw away stones
and a time to gather stones together
a time to embrace and a time to refrain
from embracing
a time to seek and a time to lose
a time to keep and a time to throw away
a time to terror and a time to sow
a time to keep silence and a time to
speak
a time to love and a time to hate
a time for war and a time
for peace
what gain have the workers from their
toil
i have seen the business that god has
given to everyone
to be busy with he has made everything
suitable for its time
moreover he has put a sense of past
and future into their minds
yet they cannot find out what god has
done
from the beginning to the end
i know that there is nothing better for
them
than to be happy and enjoy themselves as
long as they live
moreover it is god's gift that all
should eat
and drink and take pleasure in all their
toil
i know that whatever god does endures
forever nothing can be added to it
nor anything taken from it
god has done this so that all should
stand
in awe before him
that which is already has been
that which is to be already is
and god seeks out what has gone by
the word of the lord
let us pray psalm 22 23 together in
unison
the lord is my shepherd i shall not want
he maketh me to lie down in green
pastures
he leadeth me beside the still waters
he restoreth my soul he leadeth me in
the paths
of righteousness for his name's sake
yea though i walk through the valley of
the shadow of death
i will fear no evil for thou art with me
thy rod and thy staff they comfort me
thou preparest a table before me
in the presence of mine enemies
thou anointest my head with oil
my cup runneth over surely goodness
and mercy shall follow me all the days
of my life
and i will dwell in the house of the
lord forever
o ship of state thou
to sail on o ship of state
sail on o union strong and great
humanity with all its fears
with all the hopes of future years
is hanging breathless on thy fate
we know what master laid thy keel
what workmen wrought thy ribs of steel
who made each mast and sail
and rope what anvils rang
what hammers beat in what a forge
and what a heat were shaped
the anchors of thy hope
fear not each sudden sound and shock
tiss the wave and not the rock
tis but the flapping of the sail
and not a rent made by the gale
in spite of rock and tempest roar
in spite of false lights on the shore
sail on not fear to breast the sea
our hearts our hopes are all with thee
our hearts our hopes our prayers
our tears our faith triumphant
over our fears our all with thee
are all with thee sail on daddy
say alone
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the holy gospel of our lord jesus christ
according to matthew
glory to you lord christ
when jesus saw the crowds he went up the
mountain
and after he sat down his disciples came
to him
then he began to speak and taught them
saying
blessed are the poor in spirit for
theirs
is the kingdom of heaven blessed are
those who mourn for they will be
comforted
blessed are the meek for they will
inherit the earth
blessed are those who hunger and thirst
for righteousness
for they will be filled
blessed are the merciful for they will
receive mercy
blessed are the pure in heart for they
will see god
blessed are the peacemakers for they
will be called children
of god blessed are those who are
persecuted for righteousness sake
for theirs is the kingdom of heaven
the gospel of the lord praise to you
lord christ
let us pray may the words of my mouth
and the meditations of
all our hearts be always acceptable in
your sight oh god our strength
and our redeemer amen
i want to begin this morning with an
apology despite what i have written
here i will undoubtedly slip into an old
habit
of referring to senator warner as simply
the senator now i mean no disrespect
to all who have earned that title but
embarrassingly
it wasn't until i was in middle school
that close family friends
pointed out how strange it was our
family habit
of simply referring to him as the
senator there's more than one you know
well in our house that was not true
there was only
john warner and i'm afraid i have yet to
break that habit
just for a bit of context i had the
audacity to be born in a campaign year
to senator warner's chief of staff who
also happened to be a female
which was a rare thing in the 1980s
this meant that i became the youngest
member of the campaign staff
staffers became inadvertent babysitters
and i was enveloped into the family of
warner brothers
and sisters it's been an unparalleled
journey but what i want to make sure you
know about my experience
is that it was not at all unique there
are more
stories about this senator from virginia
about the impact about how there are
more stories about how this senator from
virginia made an impact
on our residents on our country than
there are seats in this cathedral
and i want to spend just a few moments
this morning reflecting
on why that is it was a part of senator
warner's character
and the climate he nurtured to lead
with curiosity and curiosity
is the birthplace of meaningful
relationship
it is that exact same curiosity that we
experienced in senator warner
that points us towards the very holiness
we find
in jesus now curiosity goes against
our human instinct in many ways
we are too busy too important too
self-assured to stop and take time
to listen and to learn from those whom
we meet along the way
but senator warner was the antidote to
this cultural norm
a master of curiosity if you will
it appeared when driving home from
political events across the state
instructing his weary staffer to stop at
the sixth consecutive antique shop
never tiring of the life story of a
craftsman
or a small business owner it appeared in
his weekly trips to the farmers market
no matter the world's state of chaos or
the fragile state of his own health
it was as if the people fed him as much
as the goods from their farms
the same curiosity was perhaps a great
source of frustration for his staff
and fellow party members when it
appeared in his earnest
desire to work with politicians on all
sides of the aisle never forgetting the
greater column
that had led him to public service in
the first place
his curiosity was the inspiration for
seemingly brief
encounters that left a lifelong
impression
on the children of staff members
committee interns
and countless members of our armed
forces
it meant that though he may have walked
into the room as an
honored guest that was never how he
behaved
always hopeful that he would learn
something new
here's the thing about the curiosity we
experienced in senator warner
it was never partial or self-serving
rather it was a commitment to a way of
life
whether a high-ranking politician
well-pinned
military official neighbor or
member of the warner brothers and
sister's family
we all experienced the same
john warner the gift he gave us in his
curiosity
is a habit that pointed beyond himself
to something much much larger something
beyond
that which was visible and holy
dedicating himself to a life of
curiosity
senator warner found holiness in
unexpected places
he gave us the greatest gift imaginable
helping to train our eyes
toward the holiness that is to be found
in one another the beatitudes
which we just heard from matthew's
gospel is one of the most familiar
passages
in all of christian scripture it is also
a framework
for the discipline of curiosity
imagine for a moment the people the
brokenness
the need and also the potential
that jesus encountered in his ministry
and travels
i imagine it was not unlike that which
an elected official encounters
when traveling throughout one's
jurisdiction
it would be easy and understandable to
dismiss
the laundry list of concerns that are
brought to his attention
notice what happens though jesus points
them towards the hopefulness
of resurrection jesus points them
towards the hopefulness
of the cross jesus points them towards
an eternal promise
which will out measure that which they
experience
in the moment this is only possible
because of the wholeness the
all-incoming
encompassing nature of curiosity which
leads to god's very wholeness
wholeness leads to holiness
within each individual beatitude is the
full scope
of the life we have in christ from death
to resurrection
the first clause reveals something about
the cross
poor in spirit mournful
meek and the second clause
about resurrection comfort
inheritance fullness
and it is in between these two extremes
where we live our life look again to
this passage
in between the first part of the phrase
and the last there is a comma
which marks this lifelong pause that we
are given on earth
blessed are the poor in spirit for they
will receive the kingdom of god
it is between the beginning of our
earthly life and the beginning of our
eternal life with god
where we are invited to allow each
beatitude
to shape our very nature blessed are the
meek
for they will inherit the earth
senator warner took that lifelong
opportunity as
a serious invitation and filled his
earthly time with a willingness
to come face to face with death and
brokenness
as well as the power of resurrection
he understood the significance of the
narrative that god had gifted us
in jesus
the reverend sam wells provides a
corrective commentary on the beatitudes
it's not about you changing the world
one beatitude at a time
it's about letting god change you
the wholeness of senator warner's
curiosity
meant that the nature of his life was
characteristically open
to this work of transformation the
senator didn't speed
past the ordinary everyday moments that
afforded
opportunities to fully witness
the cruciform shape of life it wasn't
about converting people
to his religion his political party or
his own point of view
it didn't matter if you were a christian
a republican or
even an american it was enough
to him that you were you
there was enough promise in your
potential to be worth
his time and that was what made him
different
it is this piece of his legacy that
invites us to continue
to learn from him senator warner
understood the deep power of jesus
and the promise of the resurrection to
constantly point
beyond that which could be seen
we've gathered together today to honor
senator john mortar
all he accomplished but much more
importantly
all that he meant to each of us the gift
that comes to us and his legacy is
so much bigger than the man himself the
stories
the legends and tales about him
reach far beyond that which could be
contained by a single human
and yet you and i know it to be true
because the wholeness
of his curiosity pointed us towards
something
much greater true holiness
the grace of god is that death does not
have the final word
god's promise to us points to something
much
more enduring than this life
now forever held in love by the god who
made him
his curiosity has finally been met
he sees god face to face and he knows
even as he is perfectly known
so do not dwell in a place of mourning
you know he would not want it that way
turn instead to the curiosity which
shaped his life
and which will continue to bless the
lives of all whom you
encounter if you're courageous and
patient
enough to go the way of curiosity
amen
[Music]
[Music]
shelter of the lord in
his shadows
[Music]
is
[Music]
will
[Music]
fear
[Music]
is
[Music]
you need
[Applause]
[Music]
falling
[Music]
shalt
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
upon their hearts they will
bear you lest you
dash your foot against us
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
please stand as you are able
in the assurance of eternal life given
at baptism let us proclaim our faith
and say i believe in god
the father almighty creator of heaven
and earth i believe in jesus christ
his only son our lord he was conceived
by the power of the holy spirit
and born of the virgin mary he
suffered under pontius pilate was
crucified
died and was buried he descended to the
dead
on the third day he rose again
he ascended into heaven and is seated at
the right hand of the father
he will come again to judge the living
and the dead
i believe in the holy spirit the holy
catholic church
the communion of saints the forgiveness
of sins
the resurrection of the body and the
life
everlasting amen
let us pray together in the words our
savior taught us
our father who art in heaven
hallowed be thy name thy kingdom come
thy will be done on earth as it is in
heaven
give us this day our daily bread
and forgive us our trespasses as we
forgive those who trespass against us
and lead us not to do temptation but
deliver us from evil
for thine is the kingdom and the power
and the glory forever and ever
amen for our brother john
let us pray to our lord jesus christ who
said
i am resurrection and i am life
lord you consoled martha and mary in
their distress
draw near to us who mourn for john and
dry the tears of those who weep
you wept at the grave of lazarus your
friend
comfort us in our sorrow hero
you raise the dead to life give to our
brother
eternal life hear us
you promised paradise to the thief who
repented
bring our brother to the joys of heaven
our brother was watched washed in
baptism and anointed with the holy
spirit
give him fellowship with all your saints
he was nourished with your body and
blood grant him a place
at the table in your heavenly kingdom
hear us
comfort us in our sorrows at the death
of our brother
let our faith be our consolation and
eternal life
our hope
father of all we pray to you for john
and for all those whom we love but see
no longer
grant to them eternal rest let light
perpetual shine upon them
may his soul and the souls of all the
departed
through the mercy of god rest in peace
amen we seem to give him back to you
dear god
who gave him to us yet as you did not
lose
him in giving so we have not lost him
by his returning not as the world gives
do you
give o lover of souls what you give
you do not take away for what is yours
is ours
always if we are yours
life is eternal and love is immortal
and death is only a horizon and a
horizon is nothing
but the limit of our sight lift us up
strong son of god that we may see
further
cleanse our eyes that we may see more
clearly
draw us closer to yourself that we may
know ourselves nearer to our beloved
who are with you and while you prepare a
place for us
prepare us for that happy place that
where they are
and you are we too may be
through jesus christ our lord
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
give rest o christ to your servant with
your
are new saints neither sign but
life everlasting
you only are immortal the creator and
maker of mankind
and we are mortal formed of the earth
and to earth shall we return
for so did you ordain when you created
me saying
you are dust and to dust you shall
return
all of us go down to the dust yet even
at the grave we make our song
alleluia alleluia alleluia
give rest o christ your servant with
your saints
where sorrow and pain are no more
into your hands o merciful savior we
commend your servant john
acknowledge we humbly beseech you a
sheep of your own fold a lamb
of your own flock a sinner of your own
redeeming
receive him into the arms of your mercy
into the blessed rest of everlasting
peace
into the glorious company of the saints
in light
amen
[Music]
see
[Music]
me
[Music]
is
[Music]
songs
[Music]
let us go forth in the name of christ
thanks be to god
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
mummy
[Music]
[Music]
you